kiernan the fans have just finished
binging
part four of chilling adventures of
sabrina we have so much to discuss
ready to dive in i'm so ready and so
excited
when you read the part four finale and
saw that
both sabrina's were going to die and
that we're ending in the sweet hereafter
what was your initial reaction i
was very surprised really i was
reading the script i think i've sort of
had the
same mentality as everyone else which is
sabrina can't die she's sabrina we can't
oh there's no more pages i think that's
it
uh guys but uh
you know it's a dramatic ending it's a
really dramatic ending
at the end of the day i think what it
represents is that she she truly is a
selfless soul
and sacrifices herself for the greater
good
which is hefty hefty very hefty and i
think it hit me emotionally quite a bit
it's not an easy ending to just digest
there's there's i think a lot of
meaning and impact behind it however you
wish to read into that
um but above all else yes i was i was
completely surprised
i feel like fans are going to freak
because i know that when i watched it i
could not process it but the more you
think about it and the more time you
take
it seems like the only fitting end
considering all the chaos pun intended
she's been through how do you feel about
it now that you've had
a little over a year to digest now that
i have enough separation from it i have
a
i'm of a few different minds one is one
is that you know the character
does not belong to me solely it belongs
to the
fans and it belongs to the viewers so
if people want to watch the finale and
think that she ends up in the suite here
after forever and ever with nick
amazing i will say i think she's pretty
savvy and could find her way back to
greendale if
if she chose to um
and i think just because i love her so
much that's what i want to think happens
and i i hope that uh
other people feel like
it's not the end of sabrina but just the
next phase of whatever
kind of crazy life or afterlife she may
lead
anything's possible in in the world of
uh sabrina so that's sort of where i
where i sit with it
is that i i hope that she gets back like
like so you're telling me there's a
chance like we could i would love that
yeah would you do you think we could see
this character again we never went to
riverdale
i know look i think we can still go to
riverdale i think
i'm holding out hope that she just pops
up it's like
oh man i landed in the wrong uh wrong
county
but ends up getting trapped there for a
little bit i think that'd be funny
would you ever or could you ever think
that we could do like a sabrina wrap up
movie
if there's enough fan cry i would love
that i would absolutely love that i mean
i i think i've certainly seen and heard
the fan cries and i'm
i'm with everyone that i love this
character and i love those people so
much
that whatever we can do to to to wrap it
up
um for the fans and and keep it going
and keep
sabrina alive uh pun intended not
intended
i don't know would be great
well i i just love to hear you say that
because
you know it's been so long it's been a
traumatic year if you were to say to me
like i've put her to bed like i would
completely understand that so it's good
to know that you still have like that
connection to her
i adore her and any chance i could get
to revisit that world and live in it for
another minute i definitely would
it was so great to see the bookends
between the pilot and the finale
of especially the the parallels of the
scenes with harvey and sabrina and nick
and sabrina doing that same
chase up to the porch scene i couldn't
believe that i was seeing that
what did that mean for you to be able to
film that and kind of have that kind of
full circle moment
it was wild i mean i'm obsessed with
things coming full circle in the general
sense i feel like there's something so
deeply satisfying and moving about that
sort of
angle and it felt very earned
it felt very earned and it felt very
grounding
and you know sometimes life feels like
it goes really quickly and sometimes it
feels like it goes really slowly but in
that moment it felt like oh my goodness
the past two years have just
flashed you know by my eyes
and and now i'm here doing this with
gavin
same shot that i was doing you know
month one as a little baby 18 year old
not knowing what she was getting herself
into and
that to me was really special it was
very special seeing the hole
just kind of sparked between nick and
sabrina i was not expecting it and i was
not expecting to be so charmed by this
coupling
um but the fans really were so vocal
about how much they loved the pairing
together
gavin and you have such a great dynamic
both as friends
and on screen what do you think about
the fact that
you guys kind of broke canon a little
bit and nick and sabrina
actually were endgame i think it's
powerful i think that because we started
off with sabrina and harvey
we sort of we were sort of um
i don't even know how to say it we were
really paying homage to
the original sitcom by feature by having
harvey
as a character in a lot of ways i mean
that was such an iconic part
of sabrina the teenage witch um
but in chaos fashion to redefine it all
i think it did make sense for sabrina to
end up with someone else
and nick is obviously a great
very witchy very sexy candidate for that
and i think it
um i think they're wonderful together i
really do
they had like a romeo and juliet ending
almost it's pretty much that
it's pretty much that i just love how he
just walks up casually and he's just
like i went swimming in the sea of
sorrows like aka like i committed
suicide for you boo
i was like whoa no crash like we're just
i'm 16 that's a lot
so she's 17 now oh yeah 17 i
know i keep forgetting how crazy that
all of that was supposedly taking place
over one year like can you still process
that
like what i mean it's just what a gal
i would yeah i would not be uh
as uh in as good a shape as she was by
the end of all that
seriously as you look back at your time
playing this character do you have a
rose and a thorn
on your time on sabrina sure i mean i
think that the
the roses are uh it's a bouquet it's a
bouquet if you will
um of people and memories and things
but and i could say it i could say so
many things but i think on a personal
level
it taught me a lot about myself
and it was really nice to go to work
every day
playing someone that was kind
and led with her heart and was very uh
fierce in her beliefs i think that
i'm an actor i love playing people that
are messed up and flawed
and don't have good intentions but to be
growing up
to be going from 18 to 20 and playing
someone who really did approach life
with such a zest
and such um such a such a passion
for the people that she loved that to me
was really inspiring in my own life so
i'd say the rose is just that you know
two very formative years of my life were
heavily influenced by a character that i
really adored
and as far as a thorn goes
you know i didn't i don't love that i'm
allergic to cats
i wish i like i really really wish
that i wasn't um and the hives
were not great there was one scene
where i you know i was at 11 o'clock at
night
and i forgot that we were working until
like four and i took a benadryl and i
watched this episode and i can tell i'm
like
on benadryl in a couple scenes if you
know what i mean you know what i mean oh
yeah
so i i mean i felt i felt drugged um i
was like slurring my words in this
in this one scene and luckily we have
amazing editors so i don't think anyone
can uh
can tell and i'm keeping it to myself
but i know
i know um yeah i would say that you know
those long hours you know
are are brutal on the body sometimes
and when this when when we wrapped i was
probably sleeping like 12 hours a night
for a good solid month
yeah so physical exhaust exhaustion
definitely exists
but i wouldn't trade it i would not
trade it watching you sing a sweet child
of mine
in part four was like a series highlight
and this show unexpectedly gave us so
many musical moments
uh which one stands out for you i think
total eclipse of the heart was my
favorite to sing
um like vocally performance wise it was
like so emotionally driven
and i loved that and it was like the
last scene of the day
and we everyone was sort of just getting
choked up
by the end of it so i think that was
probably my favorite
between speech out of mine was so fun
um and it was just fun to kind of rock
out and do something different that's
the thing with chaos that i love is that
it's sort of a playground
too i mean we don't we don't always take
ourselves too seriously
and there are moments that are just very
campy and fun and heightened
and uh that was one that definitely uh
definitely was that you and i have been
chatting since the very beginning
and uh we've always talked about your
hairstyles on the show
but now we can be really honest what did
you think of the wig
how do you feel about headbands now
break it down for me geeks
oh my goodness i have such a
relationship now
with that sabrina hairdo it's so funny
because
when i auditioned for the show i was
brunette i had long brown hair
and i was it was supposed to be a one
and done audition it was supposed to be
like screen test you're out
i screen tested i called my managers i
was like it went really well
i'm going to new york for the week
there's no chance that they're going to
need me back for another one right yeah
yeah i know karen you're good it was
that was a screen test that was it you
know
now we just it's a waiting game i said
okay i'm you know going to new york i'm
you know i was signed up for this this
week-long shakespeare workshop
because i wanted to just do something
different and i landed at jfk
and i got a call that was like we want
you back and we want you blonde
and ever since that and and they wanted
to put wigs on me
for to to you know to make it look as
sabrina-like as possible and i said nope
i'm dying my hair
i'm i'm i'm just gonna do it i don't i
don't care if i don't get it
i'm still gonna dye my hair blonde just
to feel like i did everything i could
ever since then you know i've had such
an interesting relationship with sabrina
and that damn hairdo and all the things
and all the iterations i love it
i love i love when her hair turns white
it's a huge
it's a huge moment for her it's iconic
it's when she really fully assumes
you know you know her power as a witch
and i think that's that's very
representative of her as a character
um on a personal level i was able to
keep my hair really healthy once the wig
came on because i was not having to dye
my hair every like three or four weeks
uh so so all in all i think the wig was
a great experience
i i really really really loved it i
really had a good time with it you know
there are certain days where you kind of
wish that you
didn't have something glued on your head
but um
you know pros and cons to everything
right definitely i don't think i would
ever wear a headband
in my real life though now like at least
in the near future i feel like it's a
little weird
like it's a little bit like like like i
don't know if there's just something
about it
that feels a little uh two on the nose
if you ever have to wear
a headband it's just going to be like eh
so you're trying to say something with
that yeah i don't think i can ever just
casually wear a black headband now which
is fine i'll take it
you know for you know two wonderful
seasons of chaos i will take not being
able to wear a black headband and be
taken seriously so
we're good well karen it's been so great
watching your career just
blossom from mad men where you were such
a scene stealer
to being a number one on chaos uh what
is next for you
what are you hoping to tackle next oh my
goodness so many things
i i have a couple really fun projects
lined up for 2021 which i'm very excited
about
i'm sort of in a creative development
mode right now which has been
super fun i worked on a show called
swimming with sharks and waiting to see
where that lands
so i've got some stuff stuff in the
canon stuff in the works
and uh i don't know that's sabrina movie
maybe
let's do this wait we need the sabrina
movie and we need
at least you on riverdale let's do it
we're going to i'm so down i want to go
we're going to make this happen and then
i need to be on set for it because i
need to see it with my own eyes
perfect amazing we can't end this here
leanne we got to keep
we've gotta keep this good thing we have
going we've got to get
i'm not ready to say goodbye to sabrina
i know you're not we need at least one
more
perfect this isn't goodbye then this
isn't yes this is a little high
this is i'll see you soon it's a see you
soon